so one of the new emerging kind of
information technology revolutions that
we're seeing nowadays this idea of
augmented reality right this notion of
taking the world of everyday perception
and tweaking it and augmenting and
impregnating perception with mindedness
with agency with aesthetics right and so
how do we do that well it essentially
means that the information technologies
the instruments that we're using today
to manipulate and transform the world
are now allowing us to overlay digital
information on top of the physical world
they apps already that looking through
the camera in the app you can place
virtual elements into real environments
with this notion that you're mapping the
real world and overlaying agency
information gamification mind into it so
what does that mean it means that more
and more of the world starts to feel
Riaan chanted more and more of the world
can be turned into gamified experiences
there's more cognitive activity
occurring in the interface between self
and world until self and world become
become one I think that's where we're
heading it's certainly the idea of
augmenting reality is part of what it
means to be human from the moment that
we started to create architecture to put
objects in the world to make art to
carve tools we've been augmenting
reality so for the digital revolution to
finally catch up to that is a perfectly
natural emergence